let's get some analysis from george
washington university law school
professor jonathan turley thanks for
being here my pleasure you know we
followed this every day and what do you
look at here and what's your assessment
of it
well the evidence is overwhelming i mean
the defense really didn't lay a glove on
the evidence there is a very damning
text message the day before this meeting
where sussman says
that i
expressly says i'm not here representing
a client i'm just coming forth basically
a citizen
the the durham prosecutions he made
really short work of that and showed
that he was billing for that time and he
was
he was intimately involved in the in the
creation and distribution of the alpha
bank
scandal which proved to be completely
groundless
but there were moments at the trial that
were really quite uh breathtaking i mean
you can see what durham's up against at
one point he asked baker the former fbi
general counsel uh one of when the
lawyers asked why did you wait to give
us
hand over that that incriminating text
and he just said sussman's a friend of
mine this is your investigation not mine
and all of us were like wow because you
were one of the top people the fbi and
you're talking to the justice department
so you know for somebody sitting at home
and we've been putting out the facts and
putting out the day-to-day developments
but piece it all together for him why
does this matter
well matters a lot we have learned a lot
it is there's been questions raised as
why the mueller investigation did not
uncover or reveal some of these details
what we now have
is a very clear pattern in both the
steele dossier and the alpha bank
scandal both of them originated with the
clinton campaign the clint campaign hid
the funding of the steele dossier was
recently fined by the fvc for doing that
so they pushed these two separate
parallel tracks both went to the fbi
both went to the cia
both went to favorable people in the
media and they unleashed to this torrent
of media attention without telling them
that it originally came from somebody
tied to the campaign that's right and
what was really telling it this came out
towards the end of the trial one of the
fbi agents sent a note saying that that
james comey the former director of the
fbi and all of his leadership aides were
quote fired up to to get going on the
alpha bank uh
allegations what was striking about that
is that the researchers that put this
together
said that they were afraid they'd be
mocked they actually said what if these
people are smart enough to see through
this how are we going to answer that
and the response was we just need a
narrative well you know what the clinton
people were right because when it went
over to the fbi apparently according to
this agent james comey and the rest of
the fbi were chomping at the bit yeah as
was the media in large part let me just
read this from andy mccarthy
fbi leadership during russia gate makes
durham's job in sussman trial very
tricky he said he was not representing a
client when in fact he was representing
the clinton campaign there's no doubt he
said it there's no doubt it wasn't true
case closed except down here on planet
earth it never it's never that simple
the crime is not making a false
statement it's making a false statement
to the fbi the problem for durham how
does he prove that sussman's false
statement mattered when the agents were
also being misled by their own bosses
yeah i just i actually i i almost always
agree with andy i disagree on this one
point and that is um it's true that the
agents were told that this came from uh
the department of justice it did it was
referred through baker that was the
whole reason sussman went to him but
baker said i would have handled this
differently if i knew it was from the
campaign the problem for durham is the
jury and the judge i mean he is facing a
jury that has three clinton donors an
aoc donor and a woman whose daughter is
on the same sports team with sussman's
daughter i mean with the exception of
randomly selecting people out of the dnc
headquarters you could not come up with
a worse jury welcome to washington d.c
all right jonathan turley as always
thank you thank you we're following all
of this hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now